Guten Tag, mein Name ist Sumera Firaat. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistant.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch hören. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich gerne. Wo kommen Sie bitte her?
Ich komme aus der Türkei. Aus der Türkei? Warum sind Sie hier in Deutschland?
Türkei ist doch ein schönes Land. Ich war in Istanbul. Ein wunderschönes Land.
Ich habe recht, dass Türkei ein sehr schönes Land ist.
Aber natürlich bin ich hier gekommen und meine Kenntnisse und meine Sprache weiter so einbekommen.
Haben Sie ein Problem mit der Politik? Ich habe einige Leute kennengelernt, die sind hierhergekommen,
weil sie ein bisschen unzufrieden waren mit den Regierenden.
Ja, das könnte sein.
Okay, bevor Sie mir über Ihre Akteurin Beschwaden erzählen, würde ich Ihnen gerne ein paar Allgemeinfragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie das?
Mein Name ist Regina Halus.
Regina Halus, bitte könnten Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen langsam und dort die Buchtebierer?
Regina, Richard, Emil Gustav, Ida, Norpol, Anton, Talus, Theodor Heinrich, Anton Ludwig, Udo Siegfried.
Um sich zu sein, buchtebiere ich noch einmal. Ihr Vorname lautet E-E-G-I-N-A. Ihr Nachname lautet THAL-U-Z.
S.
S. Okay, vielen Dank.
Frau Regina Talus, spreche Ihren Namen richtig aus.
Sehr schön, Frau Doktor. Sie sprechen sehr gut. Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Okay, vielen Dank. Und wie alt sind Sie, Frau Talus?
Ich bin 52 Jahre alt.
52 Jahre alt. Wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Am 15. März 1973.
Okay, 15. Dritte 1973.
Ja.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie, Frau Talus?
1,68 m.
1,68 m. Und wie viel wegen Sie so seid?
Unser Sieb.
73 kg.
Okay, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie heute so um?
Ich habe, jetzt, weil Sie mich das Gewicht gefragt haben,
ich habe so in circa einem Jahr,
circa 10 bis 12 kg verloren, ohne dass ich etwas verändert habe.
Ich freue mich natürlich, dass es besser ist.
Aber das ist mir aufgefallen, das wollte ich Ihnen nur sagen.
Okay, Sie haben seit einem Jahr circa 10 bis 12 kg verloren.
Ja, das fühle mich schon besser. Es ist auch gut so.
Aber ich habe da jetzt keine spezielle Diät gemacht oder sonstiges.
Okay, Sie haben keine spezielle Diät gemacht oder nicht mehr Sport gemacht.
Trotzdem haben Sie diese Gewicht.
Genau.
Okay, außer Gewichtsabnahme gibt es noch andere Beschwerden?
Ich komme jetzt mit den Beschwerden, weil ich jetzt seit circa eine Woche
Oberbauchschmerzen habe.
Wo genau haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
In der Mitte oder rechts Seite gelingt es?
Hier in der Mitte und ein bisschen rechts davon, ja.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Das ist langsam, das habe ich eigentlich immer wieder so ein bisschen gehabt.
Aber die waren schnell wieder weg.
Und jetzt sind sie aber anhaltend.
Und da mache ich mich jetzt ein bisschen Sorgen.
Ja, verstehe.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit einer Woche sind die Beschwerden dauerhaft.
Seit wann haben Sie eigentlich diese Beschwerden?
Ich glaube, in den letzten zwei bis drei Monaten habe ich das immer wieder gehabt.
Okay, verstehe.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen zurück und sich und...
Das ist immer sehr unterschiedlich.
Manchmal habe ich so ein Stechen, das hängt auch ein bisschen ab,
wie viel ich esse.
Wobei ich muss sagen, ich habe auch nicht mehr so viele Schmerzen.
Ich habe ja so viel Appetit und kann auch nicht mehr so viel essen wie früher.
Aber je nachdem, was ich esse, sind die Schmerzen manchmal krampfartig,
manchmal stechen, aber ich habe oft auch Blähungen.
Und ich denke, dass das auch ein bisschen austrahlt.
Okay, wo genau strahlen die Schmerzen aus?
Zum Beispiel in den rechten oder in den dritten?
Ja, in den rechten Bauch.
Rechten oder Oberbauch.
Können Sie mir sagen, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10?
Vorbei 1, 8 Schmerzen sind 6, 8 Schmerzen.
Ja, ich würde sagen so 3 bis 5.
3 bis 5.
Okay.
Warum sind Sie deswegen bei Ihrem Hausarzt?
Der ist leider im Urlaub.
Ich wollte hingehen, aber der ist jetzt im Urlaub.
Deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen jetzt gekommen.
Okay, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Ich kümmere mich um Ihre Bescheid.
Das ist sehr nett. Sie sind auch sehr freundlich.
Vielen Dank.
Ich wollte noch mal warten, aber der Grund, warum ich jetzt gekommen bin, ist,
mein Mann hat gesagt, ich habe so ein bisschen gelbe Augen.
Und meine Haut hätte sich ein bisschen verändert.
Ich habe es jetzt nicht gemerkt, aber er meinte, ich soll jetzt ins Krankenhaus
und nicht auf den Haushaltswarten.
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Hautveränderungen?
Heute Morgen hat mir das mein Mann gesagt.
Ich habe das nicht gemerkt.
Ja, bezüglich Ihr Bauchschmerzen.
Außer Essen.
Gibt es noch andere, etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt?
Das schmeiß ich nach dem Essen.
Keine.
Nach dem Essen.
Okay, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert?
Zum Beispiel?
Ja, am Anfang habe ich so ein bisschen Wärmeflasche genommen,
aber das hilft mir auch nicht mehr.
Ich nehme mir jetzt Schmerztalenten.
Welche Schmerztalenten haben Sie angenommen?
Ich muss mal gucken.
Ich glaube, die heißen Novamin-Sulfon oder so ähnlich.
Novamin-Sulfon.
Okay, wie viel Millikram?
Ach, das weiß ich nicht Herr Frau Doktor.
Ich nehme da manchmal ein bis, wenn ich starke Schmerzen habe,
nehme ich immer zwei Talenten.
Muss ich noch mal gucken, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, das ist nicht schild.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Talus, haben Sie Yukraeis?
Nein, nein.
Nein Yukraeis.
Okay.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder haben Sie schon Erbrüche?
Manchmal, aber nicht immer.
Nicht immer, aber manchmal.
Haben Sie schon Erbrüche?
Nein.
Nein, keine Erbrüche.
Okay.
Wie ist es mit dem Schüttergang?
Alles in Ordnung?
Bisher.
Ja, ich habe eigentlich keine Probleme bisher.
Welche Farbe hat der Schüttergang?
Ach so wie immer, ich kann es normal.
Manchmal ist es ein bisschen heller, habe ich das Gefühl.
Aber ansonsten normal.
Okay.
Was ist das mit dem Blut im Schüttergang?
Nein, habe ich bisher nicht gehabt, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Welche Konsistenz hat der Schüttergang?
Normal.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasal?
Nein, das geht ganz gut.
Okay, welche Farbe hat der Schüttergang?
Der war heute ein bisschen dunkel der Urin.
Heute Morgen, ein bisschen dunkel.
Okay.
Vielleicht habe ich auch weniger getrunken, ich weiß nicht.
Wie viel Wasser trinken Sie täglich?
Ja, ich achte schon drauf, dass ich so 1,5 bis 2 Liter am Tag trinke.
Ich trinke gerne in Tee Wasser.
Ja, das ist nicht so viel wenig.
Ja, 2 Liter ist so.
Auf meine 2 Liter gucke ich her.
Okay.
Frau Tolles, ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer allgemeinen Zustand stellen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Vielfach.
Haben Sie auch keine Stülphrosse,
Schweißausbrüche oder noch nicht?
Nein, das ist gut.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Das geht eigentlich ganz gut.
Leiden Sie uns unter Brusschmerzen, Luftnot, Herzrasen oder Engelgefühl?
Nein, das habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ja, das freut mich.
Haben Sie Hüste?
Nein.
Freut mich auch.
Frau Tolles, wann hatten Sie das letzte Mal Monas Wulutung?
Ich bin 52, Frau Doktor.
Ich bin schon seit fast 7 Jahren in der Minerpause.
Oh, vor 7 Jahren.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig zum Frauenarzt?
Nein, ich war vor das letzte Mal vor 3 Jahren.
Ich habe bisher keine Probleme.
Keine Probleme?
Nein.
Aber du hast das mindestens einmal pro Jahr.
Ja, ich mag keine Ärzte.
Ich verstehe.
Frau Tolles, ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen zur Vorgeschichte stellen.
Bitte schön.
Ich habe eine Hohen Blutdruck für Sie.
Welche Tablette nehmen Sie?
Was hat der Haushalt?
Der hat jetzt noch einmal geändert.
Ich glaube, die heißen Candesatan gibt es so eine Tablette?
Ja, wie viele Milligramme?
Ich glaube, das sind 16 Milligramme.
Wie oft nehmen Sie eine?
Eine morgens und eine abends.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Das ist schon über 10 Jahre.
Aber er hat mir jetzt auch noch ein neues Medikament aufgeschrieben.
Jetzt muss ich mir überlegen.
Das heißt, amlo die Pen?
Das kann sein.
Wie viele Milligramme?
Das weiß ich nicht, Frau Doktor.
Das nehme ich abends eine Tablette.
Abends eine Tablette.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Messen Sie Ihre Blutdruck regelmäßig?
Manchmal.
Manchmal habe ich die Blutdruck bei 130 bis 80.
Manchmal habe ich die Blutdruck bei 110 bis 170.
Mein Haushalt meinte, das sei okay.
Okay, das sind gute Messungen.
Aus einem Blutdruck gibt es noch andere kronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, seit 3 Jahren ungefähr.
Da habe ich anscheinend ein leicht erhöhter Zuckerwerte.
Der Blutzuckerwert ist so weit.
6,5 hat der Doktor gesagt.
Ich nehme auch schon Tabletten dagegen.
Welche Tabletten nehmen Sie?
Medformin.
Wie viele Milligramme?
Ich glaube, das sind 850 Milligramme.
Wie oft nehmen Sie?
Das nehme ich nur einmal.
Da bekomme ich manchmal ein bisschen leicht den Durchfall,
aber nicht immer.
Okay.
Messen Sie Ihre Blutzucker regelmäßig?
Oder wann hat Ihre Blutzucker das nicht normal gemacht?
Ich gehe immer zum Hausarzt.
Der nimmt mir alle 3 Monate Blut ab.
Am Anfang war das höher, aber nach den Tabletten
ist es immer stabil geblieben.
Deswegen mäß ich da jetzt nicht.
Ist die OP gut verläuft?
Ja, das war dann kein Problem.
Also kann der Sartan am Lüde Pin mit Formin nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Nur, wie gesagt, wenn ich Schmerzen habe.
Ja, Schmerz-Tabletten.
Sind Sie alarm?
Ja, ich bin sehr nervös.
Ich habe mich auch sehr nervös.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen Polen, Hauptstadt?
Ja, in der Polenzeit gegen Gräser und Hasenmüse, aber sonst nicht.
Gräser, Hasenmüse?
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ja, mein Nase läuft, ich gekrusten, meine Augen brennen.
Aber da gibt es so aller G-Tabletten, die helfen mir ganz gut.
Wenn Sie allergie haben, nehmen Sie allergie-Tabletten?
Ja, genau.
Wissen Sie den Namen?
Ich habe es schon gestern nicht, ich weiß es nicht. Müssen Sie sich noch mal gucken.
Vertragen Sie alle Naruksmittel mit Gluten, Fruktos oder Laktos?
Was ist Gluten? Hab ich nicht verstanden, was bedeutet das?
Gluten ist ein Eiweiß.
Okay.
Sie befindet sich im Narungsmittel.
Was für Narungsmittel?
Beispiel Brot oder Mehl.
Ah, nein, ich vertrage eigentlich alle Brot-Sorten, Mehlprodukte eigentlich ganz gut.
Und Laktose oder Fruktose habe ich jetzt auch nicht.
Okay, das freut mich. Darf ich fragen, ob Sie raufen, Frau Tolks?
Ja, natürlich dürfen Sie fragen, Sie sind die Ärztin.
Aber ich raufe nicht.
Sie haben nie geraucht?
Nein.
Ja, super, das freut mich. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber sehr, sehr selten.
Nur wenn eine Geburtstagsfeier ist,
oder so, aber lösen Sie nicht.
Okay, was trinken Sie?
Ich trinke, wenn dann Engläschen weinen.
Engläschen weinen.
Bitte nehmen Sie mir nächste Frage nicht über, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie irgendwann die Drogen?
Also meine größte Droge sind Haribos.
Ich muss jeden Abend Haribo essen.
Haribo sind so kleine süße Bomben, Gummi-Bärchen.
Ja, natürlich.
Das gibt es sicherlich auch in der Türkei.
Also ich muss jeden Abend immer eine kleine Schale essen.
Das ist so meine Schwäche.
Ansonsten habe ich keine Droge.
Ja, okay.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund, oder gibt es chronische Erkrankungen bei Ihren Eltern?
Meine Mutter ist leider schon verstorben.
Das tut mir weid.
Meine Vater hat dann ja so bluthoch Druck, ein bisschen Prostata, glaube ich.
Darf ich fragen, warum, warum Ihre Eltern gestorben sind?
Meine Mutter, mein Vater lebt ja noch.
Entschuldigung, Ihre Mutter.
Sie hatte Eierstockkrebs.
Eierstockkrebs.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, er macht viel Sport.
Er ist wirklich gesund.
Er ist auch ein paar Jahre jünger als ich.
Aber dem geht es gut.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf, Frau Thalus?
Ich bin Erzieherin, Kindergärtnerin.
Ich arbeite im Kindergarten.
Sind Sie sofrieden?
Ja, ich liebe meine Arbeit.
Manchmal hektisch und stressig, aber ich liebe meine Arbeit.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder, die Reiharion.
Die sind alle Erwachsenen.
Und in denen geht es gut.
Ich bin sehr froh, weil ich arbeiten kann.
Ja, super.
Frau Thalus, wir sind jetzt mit dem Gespräch fertig.
Ich werde so als eine Körperhöhle untersuchen,
danach Blut für das Label abnehmen.
Das ist aber nicht.
Es ist auch gut, so denke ich.
Ein EKG schreiben, auf eine Blutultraschall.
Machen Sie das alles heute noch?
Ja, heute.
Sehr gut.
Das ist aber eine gute Betreuung.
Das freut mich, dass Sie sofrieden sind.
Aber sobald Ihre Befunde vorliegen,
bescheide ich Ihre Situation mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann komme ich wieder in die Ekleräne und alles schrittwürsche.
Super, vielen Dank.
Dann erlauben Sie mir kurz, auf Toilette zu gehen.
Ich komme gleich.
Brauchen Sie vielleicht eine Urinprobe,
wenn ich schon auf Toilette gehe?
Nein, ich brauche nicht.
Kein Urin?
Wenn ich dann, kann ich später nicht mehr.
Vielen Dank, dann bis gleich.
Ich habe eine kleine Pause von 2 Minuten gemacht.
Ich gehe mal für gleich da.
Es gibt Fragen aus dem Auditorium.
Als Urinprobe sollte man eigentlich machen.
Keine Fragen?
Hatten Sie früher Endiabeschwerden gehabt?
Nein.
Sonst noch Fragen?
Nicht schreiben.
Was war das für eine Frage?
Ich wollte fragen,
gibt es eine Redizierung, die Appetit?
Sie haben noch Fragen?
Ich habe weniger Appetit, das stimmt.
Ja, Appetit.
Und Urintest ist wichtig, ich denke das auch.
Ein Urintest ist wichtig, das stimmt.
Also ich gehe mal in den Urinprobe ab, Frau Doktor.
Ja, es wäre wichtig.
Es wäre besser sein.
Sehr gut.
Dann machen wir eine Minute kurze Pause, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo Frau Kollegin, guten Tag.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Heute habe ich eine neue Patiente nachgenommen, darf ich vorstellen.
Aber natürlich freut mich sehr.
Bitte schön, Sie haben immer sehr interessante Fälle, erzählen Sie mal.
Es geht um Frau Regina Talus.
Sie ist 52 Jahre alt.
Und am 15.03.1973 geboren.
Sie ist 1 Meter, 68 groß und wiegt 73 kg.
Sie stellt sich bei uns wegen seit einer Woche bestehende
Oberbauchschmerzen im Epigastrium vor.
Laut Aussagen der Patienten sind die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten.
Und sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in den rechten Oberbauch ausgetragen.
Sie beschreibt, dass die Schmerzen am Anfang stehend,
besonders nach dem Essen, krampfartig,
und seit einer Woche persistieren sind.
Die Schmerzen sind von 3 bis 5 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Sie haben seit 2 bis 3 Monaten verschwert.
Sie haben eine kleine Schmerz, die sich besonders nach dem Essen
und während sie sich nach Einnahme von Novalmin Sülfat ein bisschen besser.
Novalmin Sülfat.
Ja.
Also das ist das Novalgin, ne?
Novalmin Sülfat.
Ja, begleitet, klagt sie über Gewichtsabnahme von sein bis 12 Kilogramm
innerhalb einem Jahr.
Hella, Schutul, Dunkle ürin und Ictorus, seit heute Morgen.
Flettulenz.
Flettulenz?
Leung.
Ja, Leung.
Vegetativ-anamnistisch ergab sich inapäterns,
ja, lediglich inapäterns.
Bei der Feuerkrankenanamnise erwähnt sie Arterialhypertone seit 10 Jahren.
Die letzte Messung, nein, die Messung ist meistens 130, so 80 mm Quicksilver
und sie leidet auch an Diabetes mellitus tips 2.
Die Medikamentenanamnise ergab sich die Einnahme, Kandesartern, 16 mg,
2 Mal täglich, morgens und abends, am Lüdepeen, Unklare dosis,
einmal abends, mit Formen, 850 mg, einmal.
Ja, die allerginen Anamnise,
ergab Allergie gegen Gräser und Hasennose
und die sich Rinnitis, Conjunktivitis und Tussis äußert.
Die Noxinanamnise war unauffällig bis auf ein glaschen Wein,
nur am Feiern.
Die Familienanamnise ergab Arterialhypertone,
bei der Prostathyperpilesie bei Muffata
und ovarian Karcinom bei der Muttha, der Rangestorbom,
die soziale Anamnistik ist die Erzieherin von Beruf,
sie ist verheiratet und hat zwei Kinder.
Die Anamnistischen Angaben deuten am ersten auf
Colangio-Karcinom hin.
Also sie denken gleich an etwas bösartiger?
Okay, gut, kann natürlich sein, ja.
Die Gewichtsabnahme von 10 bis 12 kg,
innerhalb eines Jahres,
Oba-Bauchschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in den Rechten,
auch Helleschütte, Dunkleüren,
Icteros Sprachendeföhe, differenzial diagnostisch,
Coledocolitis,
Pancreas-Karcinom in Betracht,
so weiter Abklärung werde ich
erst Köpeli unter der Suchung vornehmen,
die Vitalparameter überprüfen,
und Blut für das Labo abnehmen und ein EK geschreiben.
Im Labo werde ich Blutbild,
Entsündungparameter, Leba-Werte, Nieren-Werte,
Toliotewerte, natürlich Colestaz-Werte,
Amylase, Lipase.
Sehr gut.
Ja, und, ja, bestimmen lassen.
Was waren Sie noch an Diagnostik?
Diagnostik werde ich natürlich so Ersonografie,
des Abdomens,
und, ja, ERCP,
eventuell je nachdem, wie der Garngang ist, aber okay.
Oder Computer-Tomografie, Abdomens.
Wenn Sie natürlich den Verdacht auf eine maligende Erkrankung
äußern, dann sollte man auch eine Computer-Tomografie machen,
das stimmt hier.
Okay, sehr gut.
Das war es?
Ja, natürlich. Ich werde einen Konzil in Abteilung
für Gastroenterologie antworten.
Ja, aber die meisten Untersuchungen können Sie ja selber machen,
Frau Doktor. Das können Sie ja, bevor wir Sie die
Gastroenterologie schicken.
Sehr gut, wunderbar.
Ja gut, vielen Dank.
Also so wie Sie das schildern, könnte sich natürlich
eine maligende Erkrankung hinter dieser Symptomatik befinden.
Das sollte man auf jeden Fall ausschließen
mit den Untersuchungen. Das ist richtig.
Sie haben auch gemeint, es könnte auch einen
Garngangstein oder Garnblasenstein natürlich auch sein,
also etwas Nichtmalignis.
Daran muss man natürlich auch denken,
das ist richtig.
Aber ein interessanter Fall,
das müssen wir uns genau angucken, das stimmt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Wunderbar, vielen Dank.
Haben die Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch Anmerkungen,
Fragen oder Kritiken?
Wir möchten noch etwas sagen.
Ein großen Applaus für die Frau Doktor, herrrollen.
Aber vorhin war doch noch einige Fragen, glaube ich, oder?
Ich muss gerade mal klopfen.
Im Chat.
Kann ich eine Frage stellen?
Frau Doktor, natürlich, ganz klar.
Warum hier ist eine Urin diagnostisch erforderlich?
Okay, wer ist da als Internist, Gastroenterologe,
wer möchte antworten? Das wurde vorhin schon angesprochen.
Internist, wer ist hier ein Internist?
Was wollen wir in Urin sehen?
Ja, er leidet, ich eine Vermute,
sie leidet an der Bethesemalitus-Tippsweil.
Aber sie hat schon erwähnt,
dass sie ja Blutssucker gut eingestellt ist.
Sie hat dunkle Urin, aber ich glaube wegen Galen-Stauung
hat sie dunkle Urin.
Was erwarten wir bei Urin?
Was sehen wir dann, welche Werte sehen wir dann in Urin?
Urin ist Blut.
Ja, genau, welche Werte sehen wir, Frau Doktor?
Bileurubin zum Beispiel.
Normalerweise sollte in Urin kein Bileurubin sein.
Deswegen schauen wir natürlich nach.
Aber auch grundsätzlich als Algen, so wie sie Blut abnehmen,
sollte man in Urin natürlich auch schauen.
Hat sie einen Infekt, hat sie einen Proteinverlust,
Eiweiß, dann haben sie auch eine Aussage über den Nieren.
Ob sie Blut vielleicht hat, ob Keime dabei sind,
Nitrit zum Beispiel, einfach zu weiteren Abklärungen.
Aber insbesondere natürlich auch Bileurubin.
Das wird wahrscheinlich erhöht sein,
natürlich wenn sie äkterisch ist.
Aber zu Diagnostik sollte man das schon machen.
Normalerweise Bileurubin im Blut ist nicht genug für uns.
Wir sollen auf im Urin Bileurubin kontrollieren.
Ein Betracht, natürlich ist das Labor ausreichend.
Aber zur Kompletierung, zur Vervollständigung der Diagnostik
ist es gut, wenn man das hat.
Natürlich stellen sie nicht nur über den Urin die Diagnose.
Das ist ganz klar, da brauchen sie mehr als nur Rhee.
Hat sie den Blut abzumachen, so einen Rahmen und den Unt.
Aber im Rahmen der Diagnostik sollte man das schon machen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Das waren jetzt aber schwierige Fragen.
Okay, habe ich etwas falsches gesagt, sind Internisten dabei?
Oder Gastventrologen?
Nein.
Okay.
Erzb, ja, wann macht man eine Erzb?
Warum macht man eine Erzb?
So Diagnostik.
Was möchtest du wissen mit der Erzb?
Gallenstein wissen das.
Das können wir überprüfen.
Ja, nicht ganz.
Das sehen Sie aber auch im Ultraschall, ob jemand einen Gallenblasenstein hat.
Das kann auch operativ sein, auch die Erzb operativ sein, oder nicht?
Sowohl Diagnostik als auch therapeutisch wird.
Wir wollen eine Darstellung des Gallengangs,
des DHC, dubtus hepatocysticus.
Das heißt, Sie wollen sehen, ob der Gallengang noch durchlässig ist,
ob das abschließt, die Galleflässigkeit.
RCP erstens diagnostisch, sie schauen, ob sie den Kanal finden,
ob das abläuft.
Und wenn es verschlossen ist, können Sie eine Therapie machen.
Was machen Sie?
Sie legen einen Stand dann rein.
Manchmal kann man auch eine Biopsy entnehmen, glaube ich.
Um zu schauen, ist der Gallengang vielleicht mal liegne oder nicht.
Vielleicht kann man da auch Biopsy entnehmen, ich glaube, das geht.
Also einfach, um den Gallengang zu überprüfen.
Wenn sie äkterisch ist, dann läuft es nicht richtig ab.
Da muss man manchmal einen Stand rein setzen.
Und wenn es nicht geht mit dem Stand, was machen wir dann?
Aber das ist der Gallengang weg.
Aber der Gallengang ist ja verschlossen.
Eine Schand?
Eine Papilotomie, sehr gut.
Sie können natürlich den Gallengang aufschliessen
und breite machen, das läuft dann auch ab.
Oder einen Stand einsetzen in den Gallengang.
Und wenn das alles nicht geht und alles sehr dringend ist,
wie läuft dann die Gallengang ab?
Die Gallengang, nicht die Gallengang, die Gallengangflüssigkeit,
kann man von außen auch, was machen Sie?
Theoretisch.
Ich meine, man kann auch von außen theoretisch
eine Kohledochostomie.
Also auch einen kleinen, dünnen Stand,
das ist glaube ich nicht,
ein Katheter, ist das glaube ich, kann man nicht.
Ist auch möglich, aber man würde eigentlich
sehr schnell eine Diagnostik machen
und wissen wollen, ist das maligene oder nicht.
Und dementsprechend muss man sich überlegen,
ob man eine Operation vornimmt oder nicht.
Sehr gut, das ist ja eine schöne Diskussion.
Wunderbar.
Dann danke Ihnen recht herzlich.
Vielen Dank, Frau Dr. Schmeder.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Spaß.
Wir wollen dann nächste Woche über die guten Nachrichten
von Ihnen hören, inschallah.
Ich auch.
Und auch allen anderen Kolleginnen und Kolleginnen.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg, viel Spaß, alles Gute.
Und einen schönen Abend, inschallah.
Eine Kolangio-Zelluläres-Karzinom hat.
Das ist normalerweise ein sehr aggressiver Tumor.
Und der sich etwas ausgebreitet hat,
dann operiert man im Prinzip fast den halben Darm raus.
Garblase, garngang, pancreas, dünn Darm.
Vielleicht von dem Magen noch ein bisschen.
Das ist schon ein sehr großer Eingriff oft.
Die Operation.
Und das ist...
Wie heißt die Operation?
Wir sind hier nicht mehr left,
aber wir müssen natürlich auch kontrollieren.
Das muss man natürlich auch schauen.
Aber Sie sehen ja dann im CT,
ob da Luftklubben da sind oder nicht.
Und dementsprechend klar können Sie entscheiden.
Aber hier, Verdatathich,
das scheint eine Gastroenterologin zu sein, klar.
Oft, wenn es weit fortgeschrieben ist,
kann man... Ein Urologer, okay.
Kann man das auch manchmal nicht operieren.
Klar, das trifft ihr für alle Tumore zu.
Aber genau, Wipolope, richtig.
Das ist ein großer Eingriff.
Da muss man schon genau überlegen.
Und klar, sind Metastasen da oder nicht?
Und ja, das hängt noch von Fehlfaktoren ab.
Und meistens gibt es ja so etwas wie ein Tumor Board in der Klinik.
Da sitzen die Onkologen, Gastroenterologen,
also alle Abteilungen, die beteiligt sind, zusammen.
Und dann entscheiden am Ende,
wenn alle befundet zusammengetragen sind,
was das Beste für den Patienten ist.
Klar, und am Ende muss aber dann die Patientin entscheiden.
Vielleicht sagt sie, ich will keine Operation.
Ich lebe noch ein bisschen und dann bin ich tot. Auch gut.